do you
but no i think um
it's it's it's a unique situation to say
the least and it's a blessed situation
to say the least so sure for sure
you know what i wanted you transitioned
perfectly because i definitely wanted to
talk about your passion as a variety
streamer you know it's like so how did
that kind of start and then
whose idea was it for you to be
streaming these
horror games damn they're scared to die
i think it's a lot i like it but it's
just funny i wouldn't know like how did
that whole thing so
my community actually i was playing
i was playing some horror game
and i just saw like the numbers just
start going up and i'm like
all right
so then
it's funny because i keep this behind me
because i would throw this over my face
in a heartbeat and something crazy comes
up
and um it was it was definitely my
community in
the story of how i got into streaming
shout outs to my best friend we actually
met on xbox throwing gears uh the
original gears in 360.
i kept saying i want to do streaming i
want to do streaming i know i can do
this
for my birthday last year
he
bought the parts and built me a pc
you know what's funny like when it comes
to like the horror stuff i don't know if
technically alien isolation is
technically called a horror game
that's the only game that gets my blood
going man i stopped i couldn't keep
that gate
like it's one of those games where i'm
holding my breath because i feel like
the alien will hear me
you see this engagement the homie gets
you to pc you know me so continue all
with this whole chance of horror
streaming let's go
i oh god what was it phasmaphobia had
came out okay and uh let's just say i
got inebriated before i started
playing this game it's the right thing
to do yes yeah
and i was playing with three friends at
the time and i was streaming and
i almost had a heart attack on stream
because i'm like freaking out i'm like
oh my god i can't do this what the hell
is this oh my god
and it was a game called visage i think
that was the tipping point where i knew
okay we're onto something here
and
i had this blanket over my face like i
said okay i'm moving up
so you wasn't even
you were streaming halves with high
sight it sure was sure was done like
because i'm half dominican we don't play
with that demonic stuff no no no no no
no
shout out to to my wife that knew you
was dominican uh that's how she laid up
she just saw you and she i can show you
the text yeah oh why she was like
i'm not
she hit me with that like when she
watched her so she hit me with that and
i was like
[Laughter]
they can smell they own you know all
right
hello
people right about that
i remember growing up i'm puerto rican
so the same thing
can't have none of that in the house my
grandfather was like no it opens the
portal to hell
when you watch scary things or do yeah
oh he's like it opens the portal so that
they until they come into your home
with you i care for a religious because
you know my mom's jw so like i know like
it was certain like all things was like
you can't have the weapons and stuff
around the house because that you know
that's vital but so i didn't notice
about you know saying latino culture and
it says that so they feel just by having
a horror game that's important how to
devout you are but my grandfather he was
like now there will be no yo you're not
watching the exorcist in the house no
that's not happening none of that
confirmed this
after my mom's being neglectful as i
think about it like now i'm like
i was playing anything i wanted
as he stands in the middle talking about
a bloody mary and candy man
you gotta expound on this like please
tell me like it's it's so funny because
um
because again like he said it's
you because it's the spirit
thing right
and i
my cousin was so religious that she
thought uh magic and yugioh cards had
demons
she got jumped on for watching charm
like they threw the
the the tv out the window oh no
oh no
not do this on beyonce's internet
because my
lg oled that's sitting in that bedroom
yes the good grip weird
yo it's crazy look at the chat
i feel you yo bad people in the chat or
agree with it this is news to me
a lot of us come from religious housing
again both my wife what's up
it was fighting right so both my wives
are fighting and i run in the living
room
and i separate them both of them gonna
tell you a different story
uh yeah you separated me because you
were trying to save her
the other one you said you separated me
because you was trying to save up
cog know the truth
i was getting them away from each other
because i had so like tv that was in the
living room
[Music]
[Applause]
because this is hilarious
so what movie was that my ex and i went
to go the first conjuring movie
let me
tell you
right now
the whole time i'm sitting here like
this
and i'm watching certain parts
here's the kick for me because i'm a dog
person right
when the dog doesn't even want to go in
the house baby it's time to go
time to go shout out to black people for
recognizing
the african american beauty and horror
are recognizing when it's time to go
it's time to go i'm the type of person
if i see a spider in my house you can
have it just pay the mortgage
you telling me it's a ghost in here yeah
for us all movies would end shorter
than these horrible
[Music]
a white person thing about doing dumb
[ __ ] because there was a haunted like
mansion that no one went to then my
friend ronnie was like let's go explore
let's go explore
you know what you should do
i won't make it rigid but it definitely
ain't no let's go exploring no no no the
racial thing is
hello
is anyone here listen on god in them
i ain't saying anything
[Applause]
story and then we're going to transition
back into the horror stream we continue
um so i i kid you not and i'm i'm uh
i used to go to church heavy
i came home for some water in the cup
started praying and just sprinkling the
water around
baby day was not a game it was not a
game for me
this is amazing
i mean people are thoroughly entertained
by you i i think it's a i know it's
giving you a lot of stress
but it is clearly entertaining like
people love seeing you do it i i pay a
money for it
all right so you become a little bit
more desensitized to the horror being
that you uh stream it often now
like okay like do the jump scares no
longer scare you as much as when you
start it
oh no equally equally yeah no a good
jump scare is going to get you
regardless like i've watched
[Laughter]
yeah so i'm in there and i'm looking
around i'm like oh my god that looked
like a ceiling oh that looked like a
floor and it was like um yo touch the
refrigerator i see that stuff look for
real in there shout out to the
playstation vr right so and my girl
touched my arm ah man
that's hilarious yo do me a favor hustle
eddie mars in there do me a favor um put
um
well phoenix 443 twitches in there
because they ask and shout out the red
so he's like yo anybody got the link to
the phoenix
information we gotta get it go go show
us the love we gonna get him to get
these horror games popping y'all we
gonna show up a lot of love
a good thing
the the good thing about like when it
comes to like good jump scares it's all
like that redirection like they make you
focus something and then something else
happens and that dead space did that
really well